hi a couple notes up front my head of
death in the family recently so the API
that I promised in the description for
this isn't done yet I have cards if
you're interested come get an email me
and when it's done I'll let you have it
so I'm one of the two co-founders of
tabula lingua my co-founder Manu is
sitting right there
we work with cognitive natural language
processing in the simplest way to
explain the difference between
traditional NLP and what we do is that
NLP is primarily concerned with the fact
that words have meaning and grammar has
rules we're concerned with the state of
mind of the person creating the language
either spoken or written and one of the
simplest ways that we have of looking at
text is what we call blue and red so we
take all the things we can measure and
we aggregate them into two values
markdown didn't let me make that table
any bigger blue is deliberate red is
habitual you can also think of it as
resolve and reflection or quite simply
blue as your head red as your heart so
we'll look at a couple of quick examples
of what we can do with this give it to
Meg is the website of a friend of mine
who's a marketing writer and with her
permission I'm using her about page as a
demonstration and so we can look at the
ebb and flow of head versus heart
throughout the entire document
so this highlight here stands out as
both blue and red and it says I'm a grad
school dropout who ditched analyzing
crime scenes to write processes and
procedures for a sprawling New York
nonprofit and never looked back when I
talked to her that transition from her
plans to go to grad school and the the
way her family looked at her that was
like a big deal in her story of her life
that she left the the traditional plan
of going to grad school to become a
writer and then this is interesting
these three lines are actually one
sentence and it says I went to oversee
the day-to-day management of employee
communications for the largest municipal
health health care system in the country
and help them rebrand each of the eleven
hospitals before launching my writing
business so this is also a highlight but
it shows up as predominantly blue over
red so that would mean that there's more
deliberate cognitive processes going
into that line and when I talked to her
about it she said the reason that that
likely happened is she spent a lot of
time writing that to cover over some of
the messier parts of her career make it
sound good so in a sense it's she's the
the effort that she put into writing and
rewriting that line leaks into the
language and we can measure it these
other two will go through quickly this
is I have a fascination with eventually
applying what we do to things like
suicide mass violence and addiction and
so this is something I pulled off of
reddit it's a woman talking about her
boyfriend as an alcoholic and the main
thing I want you to notice is how
different the lines are and how they
don't really move together that much and
you contrast that with the Facebook
posts I made about my grandmother after
she passed away even though there's some
space in the lines they're relatively
moving together and we would say that
that means your head and your heart are
aligned and when they start to go up
here at the bottom I say she was
carrying funny and could be a
spectacular smartass she was a huge part
of my life and I'll miss her
this part here I'm kind of going through
the motions of saying the things that I
think I need to say the fact that she
was a big part of my life and she's gone
is the most important part to me here's
what the data looks like so for in this
is from the same piece of text for each
line we calculate the balloon red and a
bunch of other numbers that we can use
in different ways and so now now that
you can kind of see what the algorithm
does we're going to move along to an
example of how we're taking what we do
and matching it up with traditional NLP
so we're doing some work for sari a
sense of what it is I should probably
tell the story of how he invented it he
was working with a friend who had a
remote team and he was looking in the
emails and the guy was complaining about
certain things and he couldn't figure
out how to deal with the employees
couldn't figure out what was going on
with him and Monty looked at the emails
and and some of them there was excuses
they were scattered and those were the
unproductive employees the productive
employees were coherent enthusiastic and
so he wondered if a computer could
measure that so it's subjective in that
he came up with the idea and the
underlying model based on that curiosity
but it does what we intended to do and
over time we've figured out how to use
it in a way that's meaningful if you
look really at so cinnamon analysis we
were just talking about this you can
take three different cinnamon analysis
algorithms and run it on the same text
all come out differently so it's not
right in that there is no right but if
you spend enough time looking at
language the stuff that's highly red is
flowery it's emotional the stuff that's
highly blue is logical and analytical
and deliberate does that make sense
so we kind of do that but it's not we
haven't written down exactly what we
think the read should be but we know
what kind of language we want to see
when read is higher than blue and blue
and hot is higher than red does that
make sense so if you take I didn't do
this because I'm a used to work in
politics so I'm a dork
I usually use Donald Trump's inaugural
address as you know for fun and in hit
where where he is highly blue it's like
we will do this we will do that we will
bring back jobs we will do this where
he's highly read it's like we share one
heart one glorious destiny or some fiery
crap like that so in that sense it does
what we want and as we've applied it to
problems we've figured out how to use it
in meaningful ways and if you're
interested I mean I'm trying to get
through the basics of what we do to get
to the rest of the talk and doing it as
best I can
so we're doing topic modeling on the
inner on data set does everybody here
know what Enron means anybody who does
not you okay so we're doing topic
modeling on the entire set of emails
from Enron which is released as a public
corpus this first one we threw in this
is all spitballing we threw in some
labels operations planning communication
trading and deals etc then we took I'm
going to show you one more thing this is
the same text about my grandmother and
we can highlight certain patterns so
when red is the highest we can do that
we can do and blues the highest or the
low Delta this is important I'm sorry I
skipped it the low Delta is the most it
we call clarity that's where the writing
is most clear when we work with online
reviews that's what we use to summarize
the reviews so what manu did is he took
the entire inter on data set and applied
it only to these highlights in every
email so basically throwing out about 60
70 percent of the tech
only focusing on the places in each
email where the two lines are the
closest and reran the topic modeling
does that make sense okay and so some of
these categories are the same but then
this this last category which he labeled
random and reactive matters came up it
is not in the first modelling it is in
the second modelling and I asked him had
he gone back to look at the actual
emails that contributed to this topic so
he sent me the IDS of each one and I
sorted by the the probability that it
belongs to that category so the ones
that are most apart of that category and
all of the it's fascinating all of these
emails and we just did this
they all had they're all very long so
the I put a separator here in between
each one and you can see that they're
all pretty long and like any email set
you have a lot of hair you're going to
launch all that kind of stuff none of
that shows up in here and we're not
testing for links yes so here's a flight
itinerary one of them actually has a
dump of a huge like obviously Microsoft
sequel query he went in and started
looking at who wrote these and we have
the whole corpus delineate it by the
type of employee the executives upper
level measurement the general employee
and the legal team among the legal team
the one guy that contributed the most to
this set turned out to be the one of the
eventual whistleblowers that was
complaining to upper level management
about the financial practices and wound
up getting them in trouble one thing to
note the original validation that Mon
who did when he created this was to take
the same Enron set and to run a course
measurement across the whole thing and
this is the aggregate of that
measurement from
Green is the general employees and white
is the executives so you can see that
the employees follow mostly quarterly
pattern this little dip right here is
actually nine eleven we also see the
executives oh crap oh crap we're in
trouble yeah we're screwed so that was
how he originally validated that idea
was showing that the executives are kind
of knew what was what was going on we're
thinking and communicating differently
than the employees who did not the last
thing I'll show you is near and dear to
my heart
I was poking around hoping to find a
corpus of Donald Trump's tweets I've
always wanted to get into playing around
with Twitter feeds the look on your face
is priceless I found a website actually
I can look it up for anybody who wants
it there's a website that actually has
collected every tweet that Donald Trump
has ever sent so we're going to look at
Trump tweets for fun and profit I wrote
a quick and dirty topic modeling script
and this is the in the topic modeling
for the entire year of 2019
then I take one-third of the data by the
same load Delta algorithm to get a
different set of words you can't really
see much of a difference but I collected
the words in two unique sets for each
frame and then I figure out which words
are unique to each frame which word is
in the first group that's not in the
second and vice versa so this is not
entirely scientific there's a randomizer
and whatever I'm using and every time
you run it you'll get a different set of
words however there are always more
unique words in the second set the one
using only a third of the data and only
in the second set will you find things
like Russia Pelosi Muller so in a sense
it's taking out a lot of the noise and
allowing us to
Kisan the stuff where he was most
involved in what he was saying all of
this is still kind of spitballing we're
not using it in production anywhere some
of the other things we do online reviews
the star rating is unreliable so
somebody will leave a five star review
but have a complaint and we have a model
that's called made my day it's actually
five star reviews that have some sense
of insecurity in them that model fails
if the sentiment of the review is
doesn't match the star rating so we use
sentiment analysis to filter those out
and that's really all I have is anybody
have any questions what is the model
when I say model I don't mean like a
training model it's a an intellectual
model of how language and behavior
cognition are involved it comes from he
basically looked to see when the guy had
these emails that he wanted to see if he
could tell the difference mano looked
for existing software and didn't find
anybody found a whole set of linguists
the most famous is which is George
Lakoff that were studying how language
comes from cognition and what it reveals
about our mental state as we're
communicating in a simple way to think
about it would be if you told the same
story right after marrying your wife
versus right after you got in a car
wreck you would speak differently your
mental state would leak into how you
communicate and that's what we measure
and so it's it's a proprietary unique
intellectual model about how
communication and cognition are related
so I'm silly bit confuse about this
proposal of encasing natural language
processing with cognition or cognitive
science from the perspective our
cognitive sciences scientists hmm I
don't see the cognitive science part of
this and the initial decisions that show
us about like this separation between
words or concepts or phrases that are
more related to things like emotion and
another rationality is kind of like God
these credits actually all thing that
nobody believes or support in the
cognitive science community so I I'm
still very confused about how if these
cards so would repeat what you say has
been disproved you cannot classify
speech of discourse as being rational
there's being emotional that doesn't
they may be kind of like a folk
psychology kind of way of seeing things
but it's not something that is part of
the mother purpose of knowledge in
cognitive science my response to that
would be it started off as a curiosity
and like anything like if you're gonna
build a light bulb and you don't know
what to do when you start you to start
trying different ideas until something
begins to take shape and that's what you
did so this does what we want it to do
and I would argue that anytime somebody
says something can't be done or doesn't
exist that supposition might not be
right
please
if you're curious we're happy to talk to
you more about it I understand where
you're coming from
if my question is have you used this to
test any of the social media from the
sugars or the radicalized folks yeah I
mean we have clients now we're still
forming a business and growing it so
what that commercialization looks like
I'm not really sure
the one thing along those lines I've
done and I don't have it handy where I
would show it to you I'll be happy to
show it to you offline is the the recent
El Paso Walmart shooting left a
manifesto and I analyzed that and that's
actually a good way of visualizing first
of all it's creepy just to read but when
you're familiar with how these lines
show up how the data shows up in a lot
of different texts poetry songs Bible
verses political speeches technical
writing the the patterns look weird and
that's hard to to say without showing it
to you but that's as far as we've gotten
a lot of this is just we're building a
business and we can only do so much we
have stacks of notebooks of ideas of the
things we want to do it's just the two
of us but that is something I'm very
interested in Jacob so you all be almost
I want questions by saying all of the
things you tried on social media and
technical writing can you expand
if you can if you allowed on where it
works better always works worked for
example I'm curious about scientific
writing does it work there because it's
supposed to be really unemotional if you
actually look at it but supposed the the
easiest explanation for that is that if
the context is comparable so if you
tried to compare like social data and I
mean a technical or scientific data with
poetry they're not comparable but emails
in a company are comparable or online
reviews about a company are comparable
so we haven't tried it with scientific
writing but you're right that would be
fun to do that's getting into the
proprietary part of it I'll do the best
I can we classify language to underlying
cognitive processes an example would be
the word victory is always a word of
purpose in any context because it's
about achieving something it's about
winning so if you take just that simple
idea and expand it and classify a lot of
language then when looking at text is a
sequence we have a sequence of those
classifications and the movement is what
we're measuring how it moves from one
cognitive process to the other and
through a bunch of algorithmic work that
eventually gets turned into red and blue
based on some sort of subtext or are you
applying a meaning to a word and saying
it's invariable not a meaning a
classification yet there's an underlying
lookup table of words and their
classifications but but again it's all
based on an original model that was
created by looking at the academic works
of these cognitive linguists and
spitballing until it did what we
intended to do because there's no
objective ground truth they're just
saying that this word belong is in this
slot on the table because we often see
it here the trouble with that is words
have multiple meanings and can be used
in multiple contexts you can't say that
victory is necessarily always going to
be something that's a red word because
it's not there are no red words red is
an abstraction algorithmically very far
down the path from the original
classification yeah go ahead
okay I understand that I think I suppose
yeah
primarily I question its robustness but
the framework you've written makes sense
right because different I mean you're
gonna have different mental states that
affect language differently yes it seems
very difficult to me to generalize this
algorithm with multiple subjects
yes
okay and when it is multiple people and
we're imposing in artificial context
that these are all Starbucks customers
it's less robust from a practical point
of view if we want to get 50 reviews out
of 500,000 it's good enough
so instead so the robustness can be a
discussion that you you know the answer
it's most robust if the data going in
has a commonality okay and as that gets
noisy the robustness takes a hit and we
have to be careful about not over
reading too much into it the only other
thing I have to ask is is this
associated with any sort of publication
or any experimental report something
like that where do you for that I mean I
don't have an army of grad students yet
to do it but there are there are a lot
of academic books and studies that have
gone and do the basis of it not the
application yet is there some sort of
supplementary material we can look at
regarding services certainly their
YouTube videos that we can send links do
about cognitive linguistics versus
jeong-seon linguistics yeah on the I
could get a mix I'd we find ourselves in
a lonely place where the first kind of
technology sighs yeah yeah from an
academic standpoint I think it would be
useful to highlight the body of work
that you're pulling from and probably
that's how you're applying in so that
you can dispel any kind of concerns
about the actual utility or novelty of
your yeah so I have a friend who's going
for a PhD in some kind of psychology I
can't remember exactly what it is and he
has one of his colleagues is a social
psychologist and she's interesting
interested in putting this through the
wringer and perhaps publishing about it
but we're just at the beginning of that
conversation but I do want to show
something that I can't believe I forgot
this this is one of the simplest
examples of what this is good for we
were hired to look at an email server
from a company as in Texas insurance
company that went out of business very
quickly the state took over to manage
the liabilities and suspected fraud so
the very first pass is us with this
algorithm on that email server the
emails that we looked at in this case
we're from the CEO she's a woman and in
every email we measured the Delta
between blue and red line by line and
then averaged that to the document so in
a document where the lines are moving
together closely that number will be low
where they're like this it'll be high
that's a good way to put it emotional is
a we stay away from the word emotional
when I said emotional earlier I that's
really a placeholder for what is
habitual subconscious thinking which is
where emotion comes from if you're
talking about somebody you care about
you don't have to put like a ton of
effort into it
yeah
so we plot that variable aggregated I
believe to the week over the course of a
year and standard deviation leaves you
with outliers so this is when the emails
the the communication style is outside
of her normal range given this
measurement and then we can look into
the emails that are driving the fact
that it's out of range I am the CEO an
excellent business person I am
unqualified within a regulated insurance
world in fact I didn't remember that
Tony sits on a board and so here's a CEO
that thinks she's unqualified and
forgets who somebody on the board is
Tony turned out later to be a friend of
her husband's who was barred from
practicing insurance because of previous
fraud allegations the Texas Department
of Insurance plans to meet with me to
chastise at a minimum over Latina and El
Toro those turn out to be trucking
companies that were insuring their
shipments going across the border where
the shipments were stolen they were
filing fraudulent claims I don't want to
take a chance at the Texas Department of
Insurance here's anything before the
docs are in order
the company has so little value left
I want all cash in out ASAP so again
that's that's where the lines are moving
very closely together
yeah get the BMW's moved out I just
don't care any longer so you know when
people ask questions about what metrics
is based on or how do we know this works
when we're able to do things like this
we consider it useful does it meet
academic muster at this point not yet
you know we may go through that process
we may reconfigure some stuff we may be
in a better place to to compare it to
something that people already know
that's validating
[Music]
so one thing I would say is that you
know we we've used this in in legal
matters but not as evidence not oh the
redline went up he's guilty I mean you
don't go into a courtroom with wavy
lines but what it is good at is what are
the yeah sure absolutely
yeah and that's what we find it useful
for is things like ediscovery when
you've got a ton of documents and you
just want to look at stuff that's
outside the normal range given a context
as a first pass you know and I'm showing
you red and blue we actually showed that
spreadsheet you know we actually have a
lot of different variables to play with
and so when we're working with online
reviews I don't have something I can
show you but one model again has made my
day
and all it is is five-star reviews with
a high measurement of what we call
insecurity has nothing to do with the
word insecurity it's it's a aggregated
number after all this math has happened
when we apply that do what I don't even
know how to answer that
and so when we applied that model to
five-star reviews which sounds like it
chuck's to position the reviews that
come out are usually very gracious and
they almost always mention somebody's
name you know my car broke down but Tom
took care of me and about half of them
have somebody's name where they're
pointing out this person really made
this a pleasurable experience and it's
usually because there is some sort of
tension going into the engagement and so
when we've run that model on reviews
from different companies in different
industries the same thing happens so is
that you know academically solid no but
we have found it to be useful enough to
try to build a business around it and we
actually do have some pain clients but I
agree with you I mean I would eventually
like to go deep into all that yeah as I
mentioned my grandmother recently passed
away so I simply haven't been able to
finish it I've done a bunch of
refactoring to the algorithm itself
which is just a Python package and then
I deploy it in flask api's I just I
haven't had a chance to if you want my
business card I'll be happy to send it
to you thank you and would make it very
easy to explain away that gaps in the
explain ability because we know machine
learning models have a very poor
explained ability story and then that
way I think would be a lot easier to
sell the model you know we on our future
roadmap we have I've been talking about
this for years about seeing if we can
use what we do as unique features for
machine learning or to see if machine
what can machine learning tell us about
it that we can't see and what we do
how to solve the fundamental issue of
proving the rigor is it groupthink is it
at some level we're pushing the
subjectivity further and further further
in a way right so if 50,000 people
agreed now is it objective enough you
know so that might be a quick way to
gather data in other circumstances I
can't read his mind or speak for him but
it's something worth exploring for me
anybody have any more questions like I
said if you want a business card and are
interested in the API I'm happy to share
that with you when it's done thank you
[Applause]